[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as a good tune there was the edge and
the edge
[Applause]
now I meet me going to Bunco
maybe I should start playing with this
one
this is a masterpiece by me and mo what
a beat
it's not the fastest racket but it's
it's a nice sounding racket
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can see that such a relaxing song
this should be fun it's like an ASMR
pingpong ASMR okay it's a small name
it's all you recognize this song yeah
it's one it's one called don't forget
subscribe to on finiti indeed don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]
yep that's the one
musical smashes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is that an actual song new way to play
guitar this hour every guitar player
should practice
[Music]
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
almost next up a cowbell
I really like this Cabo
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
whoa okay the cowbell serve
[Music]
come on drop - sound let's try this out
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay I have no idea how to play this
thing but maybe I can play with this
thing didn't get the short one I guess
what has been yes yes we cannot oh the
world famous duo would you guys listen
to mine or not those music that's good
yeah okay let's try and lift this thing
up this thing is bigger than me oh this
is so heavy oh now you come and do this
challenge yes
[Music]
but that's giving me 400 say that's good
exercise it's quite easy to play with it
but a bit heavy subscribe to subscribe
we had so much fun filming this episode
today and big thanks to the band members
of Thor akela kalanit and guy Hong Kong
I won it for pouring us these amazing
instruments
[Music]
[Music]
doing
yeah I would give you money if you would
be on the street remember to subscribe
to our channel here and watch our
previous episodes there until next time